[Musique]
Nissan léger bonsoir
alors que de nouvelles frappes russes
sur l'Ukraine ce lundi ont provoqué des
coupures d'électricité on tente d'y voir
plus clair sur les images satellites
censées montrer l'ampleur des coupures
de courant dans le pays oui la situation
actuelle et là suivante environ 6
millions de foyers Ukrainiens sont
privés partiellement ou totalement
d'électricité ces coupures elles ne sont
pas nouvelles elles ont lieu depuis le
début de la guerre en Ukraine depuis le
24 février plusieurs pays d'ailleurs
dont la France ont apporté leur aide en
envoyant par exemple des générateurs
électriques et c'est justement en
profitant de ce contexte que ce tweet du
24 novembre a été publié le 24 novembre
on est quelques jours après seulement le
bombardement un des bombardements de la
centrale de zapporja ce tweet il émane
du collectif stand with you crime qui
vient en aide aux Ukrainiens victimes de
la guerre et il nous dit ceci l'Ukraine
vue d'en haut la nuit pour aider les
Ukrainiens à affronter l'obscurité et le
froid c'est par ici et c'est urgent et
ce tweet il renvoie vers un autre du
même collectif qui s'agit en fait d'un
appel aux dons et le tweet initial vous
le voyez il utilise cette photo cette
image satellitaire qui est censée
montrer un blackout une coupure de
courant générale ou évidemment ici en
Ukraine
voilà pour le tweet initial à la suite
ce blackout évidemment d'un bombardement
russe image qui est reprise et
agrémentée par la suite tantôt par des
internautes qui dénoncent un Poutine
terroriste et criminel de guerre tantôt
par ceux qui au contraire se félicite de
cette stratégie Dieu Kremlin mené par le
Kremlin et qui vise donc à bombarder à
cibler les infrastructures énergétiques
et particulièrement électrique et cette
image est-ce qu'elle est authentique et
bien pour répondre à cette question pour
faire la lumière sur cette affaire la
rédaction des Observateurs de France 24
a procédé à en plusieurs étapes d'abord
l'analyse for ainsi c'est-à-dire
l'analyse graphique de l'image et qui
permet de repérer justement les
manipulations graphiques d'une image et
on s'aperçoit que selon les différents
fils que tout simplement au niveau de la
zone
ukrainienne et bien par rapport au reste
de l'image les différences il y a une
différence de compression en clair sur
dans la zone de l'Ukraine il y a une
altération de l'image en clair il y a
donc un indice de photomontage voilà
pour la première étape pour ce qui est
maintenant de la seconde étape on
procède à une recherche d'image inversée
via par exemple cet outil est on
retrouve l'image où ça et bien dans
différentes banques d'image à la mi ici
ou encore Shutterstock ici ça nous
permet donc d'en connaître un peu plus
sur l'origine et le cliché en question
et bien on en a un descriptif qui nous
est donné par une même par plusieurs
banques d'image le voici ce descriptif
c'est un cliché qui vient du nasaf
Observatory et surtout regardez il date
du 7 décembre 2012 donc le photomontage
que l'on a vu ou plus exactement l'image
satellitaire que l'on a vu tout à
l'heure et bien à photomontage fait à
partir d'un cliché beaucoup plus vieux
mais comme je vous le disais les
coupures de courant elles ont bel et
bien le et d'ailleurs si on prend une
image satellite de l'Ukraine au 24
novembre donc date du tweet que je vous
ai montré tout à l'heure on voit bien
qu'effectivement une partie de l'Ukraine
est plongée dans le noir à l'exception
de quelques villes qui sont illuminées
et c'est d'ailleurs intéressant de voir
une autre image cette fois-ci du 24
février date pour le moins important
puisqu'il s'agit du début de la guerre
en Ukraine et on voit bien en comparant
effectivement les deux clichés 24
février et 24 novembre qu'au fil des
mois qu'au fil des bombardements russes
et bien effectivement l'Ukraine a été
plongée dans le noir petit à petit